So now has been wanting this bag,
and I decided to go get it for her today,
cause she's the best and she deserves it.
So I'm at Bottega kind of waiting around.
The guy who's helping me was packing it all up
and then walked past his jewelry store.
And I was like, oh,
she needs jewelry, too.
So I went and got her some jewelry.
And she's been wanting this bag for a while now.
She. We went and looked at it a couple different times
while she was pregnant,
and she couldn't make up her mind.
And I just. Sometimes she's too nice and doesn't want to get stuff.
So I just took upon myself to just make it happen today.
And look at her opening the bag.
I didn't know what color she wanted.
I forgot. And so I just went with my gut.
And I hopefully did it right.
Well, I think I did, because her face says it all.
Look at that bag.
Wow, wow,
wow, wow,
wow, wow, wow.
And then we open up the jewelry.
I just wanted to do something kind of simple.
And so I just got her a simple, um,
petite diamond ring
that she could stack and layer with all of her other jewelry.
The top one I got for her around Christmas time.
And yes, this is